all right Jacob Tremblay so nice to have
you here with us ET Canada first of all
congratulations on the new movie you
were great I gotta ask you because the
original Little Mermaid came out in 1989
this is way before you were born way
before I was born yeah do you remember
watching it as a kid and did you have
any favorite characters favorite songs I
do well I don't really remember watching
it for the first time just because I was
so young and I had been shown at such a
young age but yeah my favorite song in
it was definitely under the sea I love
the original version and I I really love
what they did with the new one I think
it just looks so so beautiful and and
vibrant so yeah and and I'm just I'm
just curious because you weren't
physically in this movie obviously
you're voicing flounder how do you get
into character because there's so much
CGI going on you don't really see what's
actually happening so how do you put
yourself in the mindset what's
interesting is that when we were kind of
recording
they had cameras filming us so in a way
you kind of just played it like you like
flounder was a human if that makes sense
because they can kind of capture certain
arm movements and then translate that
into you know the Finn or incorporate
your your facial expressions and and
play that into the animation as well so
um but really getting into character was
really just
um working with David in Aquafina we
just had fun with it and we made made
sure every take was different so yeah
yeah and Flounder flounder comes across
as a bit of a scaredy cat I'd say scary
fish maybe uh he's quite timid
um what are your fears in real life are
you are you like that in real life as
well are you kind of like an introverted
timid kind of guy I can be I think
I I think I get like used to it after a
while I guess doing this but every every
now and then I mean sometimes when I'm
meeting new people I get Star Struck so
definitely definitely there so yeah you
can relax around me though I'm good yeah
I mean what would your biggest fear be
because I'm curious because mine's
currently flying I'm walking alive okay
yeah it's crazy because I fly so much
and recently I've been a little scared
of flying which is weird because I've
ever since I was little and it didn't
bother me when I was little I don't know
why that's exactly what happened to me I
would say I'm quite claustrophobic like
tight spaces do you ever see those
videos of like the the tunneling
tunneling yeah
it is the worst yeah I know how do you
do that for fun
could never be me could never be me um
another trait of flounder is being very
loyal he's a very loyal friend to Ariel
is that another thing that you could
relate to in your regular life do you
have like a loyal group of friends yeah
I I like to stick with like a certain
group of friends I mean I'm very close
with my family and my cousins so so yeah
I mean I I guess I yeah I stick to I get
like to stick to one group and then you
know yeah yeah
so I was surprised to hear you actually
singing in this film
um I'm not gonna ask you to break out
into song today but what was it like for
you to to kind of go into that new area
of yourself that new Talent singing are
you looking forward to singing in future
films as well I mean
the good thing is that when I was doing
this I think I was 12 at the time so my
voice hadn't dropped yet so it was a lot
easier to hit higher notes if I were to
revisit that now as you heard earlier I
I struggled to even talk without voice
cracking so it'd be it'd be a struggle
and in the future maybe when the voice
cracks subtle I can revisit it it's not
something that I that I'm too like I
guess passionate about I like to do like
a bunch of different things and and
experiment with with all different
genres different types of acting I guess
so I mean this was like my first musical
so it was my first time doing anything
with with singing so it was a big
learning curve but yeah it was fun
experience and Jacob Trombley is uh
multi-talented because you're also a
dancer I saw you have a bit of a tick
tock going viral right now on Brookie
and Jesse's page right yeah
um I see you in the back kind of
giggling like trying to get the
choreography down no because we it's
funny because we didn't really have any
music to go so I was like I mean these
people know what they're doing so I'm
just gonna try and copy them as the best
I can you're like one beat behind trying
to hit the woe like yeah no actually
they were pretty wild actually
okay so let's talk about Halle Bailey
because she was obviously incredible in
this movie what was it like for you to
work with her oh she's fantastic she's
just genuinely a very kind person and
it's crazy to think that she is like
such a like humble person and she just
sings so well I got to hear her sing
in person and it gave me goosebumps it
gave everyone goosebumps made my mom cry
because she was a fan of The Originals
so to hear I guess like someone who
plays Ariel so well in person is just is
just amazing and obviously for fans to
come and see her perform in this film
she's a fantastic actress she's a
fantastic singer and performers
definitely an amazing cast there it was
it was great to see her in it I've seen
all over social media there's actually
been people that are asking for a
spin-off show with uh Flounder Sebastian
Scuttle is that something you'd be
interested in yeah the adventures of the
three yeah why not I mean
I think they'd have to age flounder up a
little bit maybe
maybe like do all like the AI thing with
my voice kind of change it down a little
bit because um but yeah that'd be fun I
that was such a fun set and it was so
unique like I had never done anything
like that before and I'm I'm curious if
I'll ever end up doing something like
that again because it was just they
pretty much had it set up like a like
almost like stage almost like a play so
yeah yeah we love the dynamic between
the three of them so I think it would be
hilarious okay so you're now joining the
iconic world of being a Disney sidekick
very much so there's so many iconic
Sidekicks so what we're gonna do I'm
gonna test you real quick okay on a
couple Disney sites okay so we have a
couple here I'm going to give you a line
that they say and you try to tell me the
character and the movie all right so the
first one goes hi everyone I'm blank and
I like warm hugs ask Olaf okay Olaf
movie
Frozen okay all right this one kind of
easy just keep swimming just keep
swimming swimming swimming Dory from
Finding Nemo super two okay okay fish
there you go and oh someone can be tough
well I've never seen a seen a king of
beasts with quite so little hair
that's the bird in Lion King oh wow okay
yeah you got it okay and last one here
walking is just like swimming but
without fins or a tail and also there's
no water
oh that's Alberto and Luca I've got it
you got to get that one
question I remember I remember recording
that yeah yeah there you go awesome okay
well I'm gonna give you four for four
let's go okay let's do it yeah nice well
thank you so much for joining us today
congratulations in the movie it was
amazing and I'm just excited for the
whole world to see it yeah all right
thank you